thank you
5 25 in your Wednesday morning so what
was this that we were showing you
yesterday something about a new desert
in Bridge
now whenever I hear Di and Bridge in the
same sentence I'm thinking about what's
technically known as the DI super
arterial
a ribbon cutting for a new desert in
Bridge the other day this was a major
accomplishment because we had to cross
the wash a lot of things happening here
that enables us to get all the way out
to Hollywood because eventually the
Hollywood extension will take us to
Boulder Highway because until now you
couldn't go through di east of a street
called theme road because of the Las
Vegas wash
now the new bridge takes you there you
can even see the Strat way off in the
distance with both drivers and
bicyclists enjoying the new Desert Inn
Bridge
so County Commissioners take segerbloom
Jim Gibson amongst the dignitaries at
the ribbon cutting is an 18 million
dollar project Cooperative effort
between the county the city of Las Vegas
and the Regional Transportation
Commission with benefits for the nearby
Las Vegas Water Treatment Plant buckle
up drive carefully please put down that
phone you can join the driving you crazy
conversation at traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com